[Applaudissements]
et mon cas jean van hamme a l'air alors
qu'elle exige qu'elle dit vous êtes
droitier au dossier brothier droitier
donc mais la quine jt la el-aryath bah
moi vous me demandez pas où le fracasse
murs entre copains kenji attention on y
va si je vois une personne tricher crise
ben avi ou quoi que ce soit attention si
vous êtes prêts oui kenji atteint voilà
tu peux à leur attention
kenji oui je suis avec toi feront si tu
veux la bête on vient là ça qu'ici
allez on y va à gauche au top 20 simon
cahn jeudi dont we faisait elle insère
matin
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas la bonne chemise quelques
bananes ce 2 mai